because there is there's there's
something there's there's something
[ __ ] special about hotel duvets and
just
and just like getting getting in like a
hotel bed
and just feeling like you're in a
[ __ ] straight jacket i don't know man
i [ __ ] love that i don't i don't like
when hotels do that when they [ __ ] no
yeah because
you get in the bed and you're like what
is this the world's [ __ ] strongest
man for weight loss you have to [ __ ]
like shimmy yourself into it yeah i love
that feeling you feel like [ __ ] safe
you feel covered
you're looking at me this is this is my
safe zone right now and no one can
[ __ ] touch me
i feel like a moth i feel like a [ __ ]
caterpillar who's like about to [ __ ]
oh okay what about i hate it when they
took like half the [ __ ] duvet under
the front of you yeah
yeah you get in it and it's like you're
trying to [ __ ] tow a car when you're
pulling this [ __ ] out
you're like this on the bed like no i
just i just like shimmy myself in and
i'm just like ah
i feel like i'm back in my mom's room
but i can't even see myself i can't even
shoot
myself in it's like i'm trying to get
into pants five times five sizes too
small
it's just like [ __ ] god [ __ ] god get in
i feel bad as well when they put a lot
of like
they put like a cloth on the bed like a
little like i don't know like that [ __ ]
they put on the front of the bed i'm
like get rid of that get that [ __ ]
out of here oh
look the thing like at the linen thing
or something i don't know what it is you
know what that's for what is that for
it's four apparently it's an american
thing apparently it's so that you can
wear shoes on the bed
oh yeah oh i'm i'm about to leave right
now so like so you've probably seen it
before like in hotels where there's just
like this one weird like
[ __ ] tablecloth size yeah i hate that
thing at the end of the bed right that's
the shoes
that's the shoes but they do that in
japanese hotels where you have to take
your shoes off at the front
yeah that's what i don't understand
in american hotels as as the only white
as the only white person here no no no
don't put this on me
i i i need i need your friends correctly
shoes on sofas and beds no it could be
does that trigger you as it should yes
yes of course my parents would hit me if
i did that
you kidding me i've never understood i
always thought you know when you'd watch
like
the simpsons or like american like tv
shows or whatever how they would
take their shoes off before going to bed
like
where they would like keep their shoes
on the side of the bed and then when
they wake up the first thing they would
do is put shoes on
i just thought that was like parody i
didn't i didn't actually think americans
did that yeah i i i mean it's not just
america it's most of the [ __ ] west
yeah and like as an asian i'm just like
why did the west just normalize well
like why are you all like dirty [ __ ]
like
gross our shoes on the carpet
that's just gross i mean that's what
blows my mind i'm like you are literally
dragging
like daily [ __ ] into your carpet yeah by
bringing your shoes in like yeah and
then and then people complain being like
oh man i hate carpet because it's so
dirty i'm like oh yeah because like
shoes like whenever i whenever i would
go to a friend's house yeah
and they would be like and i go to his
house and
he would be like it's okay you can keep
your shoes on i'm like [ __ ] tell
me to take my shoes off yeah i
i want to take my shoes off i would
actually write like i'm not a [ __ ]
animal i'm not no i'm not gonna bring
dirt into the house
i don't know what it is but like when
i'm [ __ ] with shoes on in somebody's
house it feels
so weird it feels like i'm in a public
restroom like i don't wanna i don't
wanna [ __ ] with my shoes on
yeah it wouldn't be comfortable though
yeah man this
drives me insane like and there's people
there'll be people commenting to me like
i wear my shoes in bed
stop stop stop
if if you want to go against the geneva
conventions just do it
do it in your own fight it goes against
basic human rights
to wear shoes in bed i love all our fans
except for the ones that wear shoes
together
my editor uh evan i went to his house
and that was disgusting
he had like he had like a a five inch
thick carpet
right i don't even know what kind of i
don't know what color this carpet was
supposed to be
but it definitely wasn't the color that
it came as this [ __ ] was vile dude
evan clean fix that [ __ ] carpet man
and they all wore like the dirtiest
shoes inside and i was like evan i can't
right i'm like have you not heard of
house slippers like if you if you
have to wear something why slippers
what's wrong with bare feet man or
socks yeah but even even if it's like
it's dude slippers it's fine
it's clean